in the beginning god created web 1.0 it
was an information superhighway of
documents connected together by
hyperlinks and it was good around 2004
we saw the emergence of web 2.0 where
more people started participating in the
web through platforms like facebook
youtube twitter and many others it led
to massive centralized tech corporations
that dominate the flow of information
and money on the internet we live in
interesting times because we're at the
tipping point of web 3.0 a decentralized
but secure internet where people can
exchange money and information without
the need for an unnecessary middleman
like a bank or tech corporation today's
video is a complete introduction into
the wild world of web 3.0 as an
experienced developer it's humbling to
get into because it makes you feel like
you know nothing again we'll take a look
at the ecosystem from a high level and
try to answer all the stupid questions
that you'll have when you first get into
it like is web 3 all hype and should i
even bother getting into it i would say
yes to both there's obviously a ton of
hype around web3 but not everybody's
buying it even papa elon said that it
sounds like bs just a few days ago i
love the vision of putting the web back
in the hands of the people but the
reality is that many of these companies
and the cryptocurrencies that they issue
are controlled by vulture capitalists
and silicon valley insiders that's not
always the case but much of the industry
is propped up by fomo and there's a lot
of scams and shady stuff to watch out
for and there are smart people out there
making a very good argument about how
web 3 doesn't have the computing power
bandwidth or storage to scale on any
practical level the shills out there
will tell you that crypto is growing
faster than the internet was in the 90s
but that's a dumb argument because
crypto is built on top of the internet
itself you could use the same logic for
tick tock crypto is never going to be as
revolutionary as the internet was but
that doesn't mean it's not going to be a
big deal here's how i look at it i think
the best case scenario is that it's like
1992 and things are just getting started
web 3 is going to grow for another 10
years and completely revolutionize the
way the world works on the other hand
the worst case is that the
cryptocurrency bubble has already burst
and as it crashes it's going to take web
3 down with it for perspective when the
dot-com bubble burst the stock of amazon
declined by 90 and they were one of the
lucky companies that actually survived
if ethereum declines 90 just imagine
what that will do to hashtag web3 but my
next question is do we even need
cryptocurrency to build decentralized
apps i built a decentralized app on this
channel just a few months ago with gun
js it uses cryptography and web
technologies and has no requirement for
blockchain technology at all
decentralized tech has been around
forever like peer-to-peer file sharing
with napster back in the 90s or
bittorrent which has a hundred million
monthly active users that being said
cryptocurrency is still kind of
essential because you need some form of
payment to build up a creator economy
and banks are not an acceptable solution
there it also provides the incentive for
people to provide the computing
infrastructure that make the whole thing
possible speaking of which how does a
decentralized app or dap on the
blockchain work let's use the ethereum
blockchain as our example although there
are many alternatives with different
trade-offs out there ethereum is like a
giant network of computers where all the
participants agree on the same state of
the data throughout the network now
ether is the cryptocurrency on the
ethereum network which is used to create
transactions that change the state of
the data when you broadcast a
transaction you also offer up a small
amount of ether which provides incentive
for another computer in the network to
execute the transaction this is also
called a gas fee and conceptually it's
similar to paying aws for cloud
computing resources if you want things
done faster you pay more gas normally
when you build a web application you
write some back-end code then deploy it
to a centralized server like aws for a
decentralized app on the blockchain your
backend code is contained in a smart
contract usually written in the solidity
language which is just an application
that lives on the blockchain that can
govern the behavior between multiple
accounts a decentralized app also needs
to have a front end which can be built
just like a normal website except for
the fact that user authentication works
in a completely different way so how
does user identity work in a
decentralized app unlike web 2.0 the end
user owns all of their data there's no
need for you the developer to collect a
username and password the end user has a
public wallet address that can receive
payments and a private key that can sign
transactions to send payments to someone
else the user can connect their wallet
to a browser plugin like metamask your
friend application like a react app for
example can then interact with that
user's wallet to do something
interesting in the ui like purchase and
nft um but what is an nft well actually
what is a token a token is just a
digital asset we already looked at one
example in this video ether the currency
of ethereum it's a digital asset that
you can trade with other people but the
cool thing is that developers can create
their own tokens in the form of smart
contracts it's basically just a number
in a smart contract mapped to a wallet
address in fact if i wanted to create my
own cryptocurrency i could do so by
writing a smart contract that gives
myself an initial balance of 1
quadrillion tokens which i can then sell
to you for one dollar a pop then you
sell it to your friends for two dollars
then they sell it to their friends for
three dollars and we all get super rich
now i know that sounds like a ponzi
scheme but everything is a goddamn ponzi
scheme with the us dollar being the
leader in this space so no need to worry
about ethics or anything in this example
we've created a fungible token which
means that one token is always the same
value as another token of the same size
one coin is always worth the exact same
as another coin but tokens can also
represent assets that are not exactly
alike like baseball cards real estate
digital artwork and stuff like that
these are examples of non-fungible
tokens each token is unique and
represents a different item which means
that its actual market value might be
different when you go to trade it in for
some other kind of currency you've
probably seen the nft craze with entire
marketplaces like open seas popping up
to sell digital artwork as non-fungible
tokens which is actually a great example
of a highly polished web 3 app now i
want to switch gears and talk about
technology what does the front end of a
web3 application look like for the most
part it's not much different than a
normal web app you'll likely use a ui
library like react along with all your
other favorite front-end tools things
become different when we start talking
about user authentication because like i
mentioned earlier the end user uses a
plugin like meta mask to make their
public wallet details available to a
decentralized app now the question
becomes how do we as developers connect
to meta mask it's actually really easy
because metamask creates a global object
on the browser window that we can use to
access details about the wallet now
figuring out what to do with this data
is actually pretty complicated but
luckily there's libraries out there to
make our lives easier the two most
popular options are web3.js and
ethers.js they provide a
javascript-based api making it much
easier to interact with the end user and
smart contracts on the blockchain here's
an example of how the process might look
we create a provider with the window
ethereum object which is used to then
create a signer you can think of that as
the current user we then connect to a
smart contract then change the state of
it which will require the user's
approval and is based on the logic and
the smart contract itself and that's all
it really takes to initiate a
transaction on the front end the front
end stuff is pretty simple but what does
the back end look like in a web web3
application well it's probably a lot
different than what you're used to as an
old-timey web developer instead of a
server and database like php and mysql
you'll be writing smart contracts there
are frameworks out there designed to
streamline development two of the most
popular options are hard hat and truffle
when you add them to your project
they'll give you a place to write a
smart contract in the solidity
programming language i have a 100 second
video if you want to learn more but it's
basically an object oriented language
designed specifically for writing smart
contracts on the blockchain that may
sound intimidating but there's a project
out there called open zeppelin that
provides templates for writing smart
contracts that comply to industry
standards making it extremely easy to
implement reliable code out of the gate
now the other thing a development tool
chain will do for you is provide a
script to deploy your smart contract to
the blockchain it's just a simple node
script that signs a contract with your
credentials and deploys it to an address
on the blockchain now you might be
wondering how do i test this code before
i deploy it because i have no idea if
this thing actually works that's another
thing that hardhat and truffle can help
you out with they can create a testing
network on localhost then generate a
bunch of wallet addresses loaded up with
fake crypto that you can use for testing
in the browser you can connect metamask
to your testing network instead of
operating on the actual ethereum network
in addition if you're building a serious
app you should consider writing
automated tests for it and there's a
library called waffle that can help you
do that that's what a basic
decentralized app looks like but one
more stupid question you might have is
do i store all my data in the blockchain
the answer is no it's not efficient or
necessary to store everything in the
blockchain and that's where off-chain
storage comes in in some cases data
might be too large to store on the
blockchain or it might need to be
modified or deleted which is not
possible in a blockchain where all the
data is read only the most common
solution is the interplanetary file
system or ipfs it's a decentralized way
to share files very similar to the way
bittorrent works and there's also
databases built on top of ipfs like
orbitdb and threaddb which is kind of
like a peer-to-peer version of mongodb
if you've made it this far in the video
you might be thinking web3 looks awesome
but how do i get started i'm working on
a full step-by-step tutorial that will
be out on the channel soon so make sure
you're subscribed to catch that the
easiest way to start messing around with
smart contracts is with the remix ide
it's a browser-based tool that will
handle all the compilation and
everything for you so you don't have to
mess around with any javascript on
youtube there are a couple of really
good channels that i want to mention one
is hash libs for working with nfts and
the other one is nader dabit just for
all around wisdom related to web3 i'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if you have more questions about web3
let me know in the comments and i'm
curious to know if you think web 3 is
the future or if you think it's just a
big nothing burger thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one